the plane was flying low and due to land
when it came down in the tourist town of
Pokhara
the plane made a loud noise we turned
around and saw a bamboo tree fall down I
told my friend that the plane was
falling to the ground then we heard a
blast
the hearts of the wreckage on fire local
people joined officials to search for
bodies and survivors
the incident was very tragic the full
force of the Nepal Army and the police
have been deployed for rescue operations
security agencies have to accept this
challenge difficult is a word that is
not in our vocabulary we are actively
working to retrieve and identify the
bodies as soon as possible and hand them
over to the families
the yeti Airlines flight from Kathmandu
was full of passengers 15 of them were
foreign Nationals footage posted on
social media shows the flight's final
moments the twin Pro ATR appears to make
a sharp turn before coming down
bystanders captured footage of flames
rising from the wreckage it could be
that the aircraft stalled um I mean
that's an aerodynamic store when the
speed is too low
um and one of the Wings stops flying
um in theory
um that should never happen
um if they had a sudden engine failure
after takeoff they should have been able
to continue on the remaining engine
poor maintenance and Deluxe standards
have led to several fatal accidents in
Nepal in recent years here in Nepal
flying can be challenging as it has some
of the world's most remote runways
surrounded by mountains and difficult
terrain it can be challenging for Pilots
to land in
the yeti Airlines aircraft was
reportedly 15 years old and equipped
with an old transponder with unreliable
data an investigation into the cause is
underway ramyata limbu Al Jazeera
Kathmandu